One of the most
powerful properties
of integer optimization
is the ability
to add what we call
logical constraints.
These use binary
variables to implement
different restrictions.
Let's look at a few examples.
Suppose we want to add the
constraint that A and B can't
play in both weeks 3 and 4.
We can do this by adding the
constraint x_AB3 + x_AB4 less
than or equal to 1.
What are feasible values
for these two variables,
given this constraint?
Both variables can be 0, or
one or the other can be 1.
A solution with both variables
equal to 1 would be infeasible.
So this constraint
models the restriction
that teams A and B can't
play in both weeks 3 and 4.
Note that this only works
because the variables only
take values 0 or 1.
Let's look at another example.
Suppose we want to
add the restriction
that if A and B
play in week 4, then
they must also play in week 2.
We can do this by adding the
constraint x_AB2 greater than
or equal to x_AB4.
Let's consider feasible
solutions to this constraint.
If x_AB4 equals 1, then
x_AB2 must also equal 1.
But if x_AB4 equals
0, then x_AB2
can be equal to either 0 or 1.
So this constraint exactly
models the restriction
we wanted.
Lastly, suppose that teams C and
D must play in week 1 or 2 --
they can't play both
games in weeks 3 and 4.
We can model this constraint
with x_CD1 + x_CD2 greater than
or equal to 1.
Feasible solutions are
both variables equal to 1,
or one variable equal to 1.
Both variables can't equal 0.
These are just a few examples
of logical constraints
that we can implement
using binary variables.
Let's go into LibreOffice
now and add these constraints
to our model.
In our spreadsheet,
let's scroll down
to the bottom of our
constraints list.
We wand to add in
three new constraints.
The first is that teams A and
B can't play in both weeks
3 and 4.
The second is that if teams
A and B play in week 4,
then they have to
play in week 2.
And the third is
that team C and D
have to play in
weeks 1 and/or 2.
So, to add the first
constraint, our left hand side
should be equal to the sum
of the variables for A and B
in weeks 3 and 4.
Our sign is less
than or equal to
and our right hand side is 1.
Our second constraint,
the left hand side,
is equal to the decision
variable for teams A and B
in week 2.
The sign is greater
than or equal to,
and the right hand side is
equal to the decision variable
for teams A and B in week 4.
For our third constraint,
the left hand side
is equal to the decision
variables for teams C and D
in weeks 1 and 2, the sign
is greater than or equal to,
and the right hand side is 1.
We can see here that our current
optimal solution violates
every single one of
these constraints.
So, let's go ahead
and resolve our model
to get a new solution.
So go to the Tools
menu and select Solver.
Now, let's add in
our new constraints.
So in the third
cell reference box,
go ahead and select
the left hand side
for the first constraint.
Make sure the operator
is less than or equal to,
and select the right
hand side for the value.
Then in the fourth
cell reference box,
select both of the left hand
sides for the other constraints
because they're both greater
than or equal to constraints,
change the operator to
greater than or equal to,
and for the value select
the two right hand sides.
And go ahead and click Solve.
The solving result says
"Solving successfully finished.
Result 20."
Select Keep Result.
Let's look at our new solution.
The objective value
is now 20 which
is less than it was before.
But now we have teams A and
B playing in weeks 2 and 4
and teams C and D
playing in weeks 2 and 4.
So, depending on
your preferences
as a decision-maker, you might
prefer the previous solution
which had a slightly higher
objective or this solution
which is a little more balanced.
In the next video, we'll discuss
how additional constraints
often make the problems
harder to solve
and how large
integer optimization
problems are solved in practice.